へいへい
ああああああ
皆さん毎年どのぐらいのプラスチックが海に流されているかご存知でしたか
その量は1年間で最大1000200万トン
東京ドームに例えると何と28杯分もの量になるんです
プラスチックが海に上がれると海は汚れ海の生物は傷つきます
プラスチックを食べた魚はやがて私たちの食卓に戻ってくるんです
こういう話を聞いてなんとか使えしてプラスチックを減らしたいと思って行動し始めた
人も多いんではないでしょうか
私もシンプルなことなんですけれどもこんなことに取り組んでいます
マイボトルを見水を入れて持ち歩いたり
コーヒーも好きなのでタンブラーを持ち歩くこともあります
もちろんお買い物はマイバッグを使っています
あとは最近では洗剤を量り売りで購入できるお店も出てきていて
そういったところに枚容器を持って行って買ったりましています
野菜は農家さんから直接頼むことでなるべく裸のまま送ってもらっています
これを見ている方々の中にもこうしたアクションをしている人達って増えていますよね
しかし
ここに衝撃的なデータがあります
このまま何もしなかった場合20年後にはプラスチックが
2900万トンも海に流れ出してしまうという数字です
私たちのアクションが増えている中こうして海ゴミも増えてしまっているんです
さらに衝撃的なことは
今世界中で企業や政府が行っている
様々なプラスチックの対策これが仮にうまくいったとしても
2009100万トンからわずか7%しか減らないということになっています
さらにプラスチックの影響は海だけではありません
日本では回収されたプラスチックのすべてがリサイクルされているわけではないんです
リサイクルされているのは回収されたプラスチックのたった27%
それ以外の多くは燃やされて温室効果ガス発生の原因にもなっています
しかも27%のうち4割近くは東南アジアなどのほかの国々に輸出されているんです
日本だけでなく先進国はこうして自分の国でリサイクルできないプラスチックをこれ
まで途上国などに輸出してきました
しかしこうして輸出されるプラスチックの中には大量の汚れのひどいブラッシュ降っ
たりそもそもリサイクルできないものがたくさん混じった状態で輸出されているんです
こういったものが原因となって現地で深刻な環境被害や健康被害を引き起こしています
例えば違法な焼却や路上での木だったり
梅田てですとか
まさに人々が住んでいるところで川や土空気が汚染されています
こうした状況を受けてマレーシア政府は昨年と今年
先進国のゴミ捨て場にはならないとして
先進国から輸出されたプラスチックが詰まったコンテナーをそのまま返送する処置を
とりました
この対象には日本も含まれています
私たちは一刻も早くこのプラスチックの木から抜け出さなくてはいけません
そのためにはみんながマイボトルやマイバッグを持ち歩くという
一人ひとりの努力だけでなく社会全体のシステムが変わる必要があるのです
世界ではシステム変化につながる取り組みが始まっています
アメリカのコーヒーチェーンブルーボトルコーヒーは毎年アメリカだけで1200万も
の使い捨てカップを消費しています
昨年ついに使いして書くから脱却するための取り組みを発表しました
革新的なのは
使えしてカップの提供でなく何度もリユースできるタンブラーの貸し出しも始めると
いうことです
このような意識を持つ企業の取り組みを加速させる事業を行っているのが
ベッセルワーク車
ベッセルワークスでは提携するカフェにステンレスのタンブラーを貸し出しています
利用者は自分でタンブラーを持って行かなくとも
スマホで簡単に登録するだけでタンブラーを借りることができます
飲み終わった後は洗わずにそのままお店や回収ボックスに返却するだけです皆さん
プラごみを出さないこのような仕組みが日本にももっとたくさん広がったらいいと思い
ませんか
ではリユースが浸透し使い捨てがほとんどなくなった社会は一体どのようなものなの
でしょうか
使い捨てのない社会を想像してみませんか
今から1分ほどの動画をご覧になっていただきます
例えば地域のお店コンビニやスーパーなどでしょうゆやみそや水を避け
新鮮な野菜や果物などたくさんのものが衛生的な販売方法で量り売りで売られている
でしょう
カフェやコンビニでコーヒーを買う時使いしてカップは過去のものになります
時間がたっても温かいまま飲めるオシャレなタンブラーを貸してくれます
環境にも優しいリユースの仕組みが地域に広がっていくことで
例えば普段自分が食べているものにもっと気を使うようになったり自分も環境に優しい
仕事をしたいと思う人たちも増えていくはずです
ファーマーズマーケットが都会でも当たり前になったり
詰め替え式の客アイサービスが始まったり
若い世代でも農業を始める人が増えたりして環境にもやさしい仕事も増えていきます
使いしてが大幅に減ることで人とのつながりが増えたり新しいコミュニティーが生まれ
ていくのです
とはいえまだ行動する人が本の一人の日本
まだまだ大きな動きには至っていません
私たちの世界は異なる価値観や考え方
バックグラウンドを持った人たちであふれています
こんな複雑な社会でみんなで行動しようというのはとっても難しいなんて思いませんか
実際のところどうなのでしょうか
ここにある数字があります
3.5%
3.5%の人たちが本気で行動すれば社会は変わるということを示しています
この研究によるとこれまで非暴力な方法によって成功した革命などは世の中の3.5%
の人たちが行動したことで社会全体の変化につながったということです
今日このオンライン会場には100名以上の人たちがいます
このうち例えばこれが100人の社会だとすれば
このうちたった数人が行動すればその社会は変わるということです
たった3.5%が実際に行動して企業に声を届けたり無駄な使い捨てプラスチックの
規制を政府や自治体に求めたり
さらに踏み込んで
循環型の授業を自分で立ち上げたり
新しい販売の仕組みや使い捨て組のでない社会モデルが生まれ始めるかもしれません
それは残りの96.5%の人たちにとっても関係のない話ではないんです
使い捨てのゴミを出さずに暮らしやすい世の中に皆にとって変わっていくんです
そう考えると社会を変えることって意外にシンプルかもしれません
一気に変わらなくてもいいんです
大きな変革は社会から見ればほんの小さな変化から始まるのだと思います
私は今こうして10分着の間お話ししていますが
なんとこのカーントラック10台分のプラスチック3が海に流れ出したことになります
この動画を見合った後すぐにでも私たちにできることはたくさんあるんです
あなたも今から3.5%の一人になりませんか
きっとその先には誰一人取り残さない社会が待っているはずです